well trinidad lopez better known as
trini lopez was a singer
musician and actor and he was best known
for his smash hits like if i had a
hammer and
lemon tree unfortunately lopez died of
copid 19 complications
just last month and he was 83 years old
well today a lot of las vegas musicians
are thankful for his role in society
his unique musical styles and what he
did for other hispanic musicians
sally jaramillo shares the story
everyone
loved that song
rick chavez is a musician who has lived
in las vegas for
25 years he vividly remembers the legend
trini lopez he was big in the
60s what happened was like
he recorded a song that
peter paul and mary did it was an old
1940s song
it was called if i had a hammer
[Music]
and unlike many trini had a style one
will always remember
he had a unique way of
strumming kind of like where he hit it
and he did it
in more of a rock style and that was
kind of like the beginning of
what it was called folk rock a hammer in
the morning musician rick arroyo moved
to las vegas in 1995
and says in the 60s you would hear a lot
of different styles of music
but not a whole lot of transitions like
that that's a nice
combination that he that he did whether
it was intentional or not
mentored by buddy holly and frank
sinatra lopez became an international
star
one who would perform both in english
and spanish
the story goes when he was in l.a
he was playing at some club
and frank sinatra happened to be
happening to go in
one night and basically discovered him
one thing's for sure lopez was always
proud to be
a mexicano he was in the movie the dirty
dozen
so watching him on tv as well you know
which is kind of cool
oh yeah aside from that gibson guitar
corporation commissioned a signature
piece
the trini lopez guitar a couple years
later they did another signature one but
it was more of a solid
more like a rock version of it today
many stars like dave grohl of foo
fighters and noel gallagher of oasis
carry those collector items lopez was
inducted into the international latin
music hall of fame
in 2003 in a las vegas walk of stars
in 2008. many musicians like chavez
narrow say
he will always be a role model to follow
i love his singing voice the way that he
would project the way that he would
work the crowd over you know a lot of
fun
and it's infectious he has such a
positive vibe so
i would like myself to be positive as
well chavez says trini lopez paved the
way for latino americans
such as santana they have a musical
legacy
that they leave behind and it's up to us
to
you know keep to keep that legacy going
and with his hammer
and song may you rest in peace
trini lopez sally jaramillo reporting
filmmaker p david ebersole finished
shooting a documentary on lopez along
with todd hughes and the film was called
my name is lopez and it's expected to be
released in 2021.
trini's las vegas star can be found
right in front of the flamingo hotel and
casino